there are tales and stories that we tell
to scare one another to prey on fears
and insecurities for our own amusement
and then there are cautionary tales that
we tell because we believe they keep us
safe
or at least they give the illusion of
safety but there are also stories like
today's that are a strange combination
of the two what started off as a
cautionary tale has now become an urban
legend and with the release of the curse
of Leia onna on the big screen I guess
now would be a perfect time to examine
the legend that we've previously
discussed but in some more detail liar
onna primarily appears in Mexican
folklore and her name translated from
Spanish means the weeping woman no one
really knows the exact origin of Layana
but her story has existed since the 16th
century during the time of the
conquistadors and today she's definitely
become what we would describe as an
urban legend a ghost of a thin woman
dressed in a white or black gown who
weeps as she roams the lakes and creeks
in search of children to drag to a
watery grave
whatever you do don't go out past dark a
liar honor will take you something that
I'm sure many of my Hispanic followers
and viewers would have heard growing up
from parents or grandparents similar to
tales of Lamia Baba Yaga or even just a
boogeyman liar Onan was a cautionary
tale told mostly to children now of
course she wasn't always this ghostly
figure who drowned kids in the river
there is a backstory or in this case
there are several explanations as to how
she became the weeping woman and judging
by the name I'm sure you've gathered
that these aren't going to be happy
stories
in most stories she's referred to as a
woman named Maria who came from a very
poor background the first story that
we'll be discussing today involves Maria
marrying a wealthy man who had a rather
shady past being an alcoholic and a
womanizer
regardless Maria still loved him of all
of her heart and she had hoped that for
her he would change his ways and he did
in the beginning he showered her with
gifts and gave her all of his attention
but this of course wouldn't last for
very long
when Maria had his two sons he began to
change returning to his womanizing ways
and turn into alcohol to fill the void
that she once filled and he would leave
Maria and their boys alone for months on
end with no explanation a warning and
eventually he became so disinterested
that he told Maria he was leaving her
for a woman of his own wealth and social
standing as you can imagine Maria didn't
take this too well especially as he
would only return to visit his children
leading her to resent them more and more
each day eventually it all became too
much and during a walk by the river she
noticed her ex-husband in a carriage
with a younger and far more beautiful
woman he stopped the carriage but only
to speak to his children before driving
off completely ignoring Maria Maria this
would be the last straw and in a fit of
rage she threw her children into the
river and watch as they drowned and
disappeared down the stream and by the
time she came to her senses
it was two lanes she tried to find her
children along the riverbank but they
were no longer in sight
in her grief she ran down the streets of
her town screaming and wailing
uncontrollably for her lost children
soon after grief-stricken and with no
will left
Maria was found dead by the very same
riverbank that she had thrown her son's
in upon reaching the gates of heaven she
was asked about the whereabouts of her
children to which she had no answer and
so she was denied entry into the
afterlife she would instead spend
eternity in between the land of the
living and the land of the dead
searching for her lost children it's
believed she was then seen on the banks
of the river SantaFe looking for
children to drown so that others might
feel the same pain and loss that she was
cursed to feel there are several one of
the versions that attempt to tell the
origin story of layered honor the two
most popular being that liar honor was
or at least is linked to the Aztec
goddess seeig Waddle a snake woman
associated with motherhood and fertility
who dresses in white and walks the night
weeping and wailing she was also
considered an omen of war many believe
the legend of layered on I came to exist
because SIA coatl roamed the rivers
moaning and weeping to warn the people
of the invading conquistadors in some
stories Maria's husband was actually a
Spanish conquistador who abandons her
and leaves her to care for her children
alone the skink ISA door at times was
even believed to be Hernan Cortez who's
famous for lead in the Spanish
expedition that led to the fall of the
Aztec empire in these stories Mira is
described as he's interpreter and
concubine quarters then of course would
leave her to marry a Spanish woman Maria
disgraced and shunned by her own people
out of vengeance thing killed Cortez's
children
there are different variants of this
story that are a little bit more vague
that simply described Maria been jilted
by a Spanish lover
interestingly enough Maria isn't always
the victim of a terrible marriage there
are stories where she was a rather vain
woman who spent all of her time partying
and neglecting her children one night
when she returned home both of her sons
had drowned and for this neglect she was
cursed in the afterlife now the stories
of Leia Rana do vary drastically and the
rivers of Mexico aren't the only place
in Latin America where people have
claimed to have seen her or at least
heard her wailing even her behavior can
vary from region to region some believe
that she only drowns children or as
others also believed that she kills men
because of her lost lover
there are also tales where she's far
more barbaric killing anyone who crosses
her path man woman or child now as of
most urban legends that we cannot
approve there are some quite wild
stories involving the weeping woman the
year is 1986 in Houston Texas and a
woman by the name of Juana tried to kill
her seven children by throwing them in
the Buffalo Bayou when questioned by the
authorities she told them that she
believed that she was layer Anna upon
further investigation it turns out that
she was a victim of domestic violence so
bad that she wanted to end her suffering
as well as that of her children sadly
two of her children did in fact die in
what turned out to be an odd and truly
disturbing story there is also a story
of a boy who would routinely argue of
his mother one day after a particularly
heated argument the boy and his brothers
left their ranch and made their way to
Santa Fe in a carriage when they arrived
at the riverbank they saw a tall thin
woman dressed in white with a black veil
covering her face
all of a sudden she appeared in the
carriage seen her right in between the
brothers leaving the brothers petrified
and speechless when the brothers decided
to turn around and head home she turned
to face them and said if you argue with
your mother I will visit you again the
boys continued on their way home heeding
the warning of Layard honor to respect
their mother as the next time they
encountered the weeping woman she may
not have been so friendly I've also come
across stories of people that claimed
during their dreams and encounters of
Layard honor she removes her veil which
means she has chosen you to join her in
her search for her children in the
afterlife which is also in itself quite
a scary thought if she doesn't kill you
then you may be cursed for eternity the
fact that I've never been to Mexico and
I'm also not Hispanic means I can't
really say what it's like growing up
with these stories but Layana certainly
seems to be more than just a ghost story
there seems to be another superstition
surrounding her and Latin America and
that's definitely something that's been
passed down from generation to
generation despite it being a story used
to stop children from going out late at
night it seems that you don't have to
look particularly far to find someone
who either knows someone or who
themselves have had an encounter of
Layard honor it is definitely
interesting to see so many similar
stories in cultures all around the world
in Greek mythology both Lamia and Medea
have similar stories being women who are
scorned and ultimately end up killing
children if we take the more Aztec idea
of her image being seen as a warning of
danger that in itself is quite similar
to the Irish myths of the Banshee who
also has a fairly similar appearance
these stories lead into the theory that
lie Adana might be similar to the
European myths because the Europeans may
have influenced the native stories
during their expeditions but I guess
we'll never know for sure a cautionary
tale or a terrifying legend I'll leave
you to decide and if you are someone who
has grown up with these stories then
feel free to share those in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained